das königs tagesgespräch jetzt mit dario
schramma ist der generalsekretär der
bundesschülerkonferenz ich grüße sie
guten morgen herr sagen da schreiben
bevor wir in die details gehen was ist
die bundesschülerkonferenz ich kannte
den begriff nicht
na ja wir haben ein föderales
bildungssystem daher gibt es eben landes
schülervertretungen die dafür zuständig
sind eben die belange ihrer schüler in
ihrem jeweiligen land zu vertreten aber
wir haben das jetzt gerade den letzten
monaten gesehen viele bildungsfragen
werden eben auch auf bundesebene gekehrt
und daher gibt es sozusagen den
zusammenschluss der
landesschülervertretung auf bundesebene
um eben den schülern auch auf
bundesebene eine stimme zu verleihen
da merkt man wie lange mein abitur schon
zurückliegt ich glaube das war vor
meiner zeit herr schreiben sprechen wir
über die bund länder ergebnisse und wie
zufrieden sie damit sind ist ja länder
politik die schulpolitik wie zufrieden
sind sie mit der politischen linie im
moment ich bin sehr frustriert denn was
wir erleben in den letzten monaten ist
ein unfassbarer zickzackkurs und das
schlimmste ist natürlich werden den
föderalismus und es ist immer einfach zu
sagen gut länder das ist eure hoheit
macht wie ihr wollt aber und das haben
wir den letzten monaten schon eigentlich
erlebt der bund hat schon gewisse
möglichkeiten rahmenbedingungen zu
setzen und in den letzten runden mit dem
ministerpräsidenten und der kanzlerin
haben wir eben das nicht erlebt wir
haben gesehen dass im endeffekt mann
bevor es überhaupt in die verhandlungen
gehen man von vornherein gesagt hat wir
können das nicht schaffen länder wir
resignieren vor dem föderalismus und das
ist keine transparente entscheidungen
vor allem führt das dazu dass auch die
akzeptanz und das verständnis für die
die entscheidung schwindet wir sprechen
ja oft über schülerinnen und schüler
jetzt sprechen wir mit einem schüler
es gibt so sprüche wie ich war öfters zu
als die schule von manchen schülern wie
ist denn die befindlichkeit im moment
ich glaube wir uns schülern geht es
nicht wirklich aktuell gut mit der
situation wir haben dieses hin und her
wir haben keine klaren perspektiven dann
kommt natürlich auch noch dazu dass
viele ihren abschluss machen viele haben
auch träume es geht auch darum
zukunftsperspektiven also viele haben
sich vielleicht überlegt sie gehen in
dem bereich xy dieser bereich ist durch
brunner so massiv beschädigt worden dass
diese träume die es da vielleicht seit
jahren gab
ich habe viele freunde die wollen zum
beispiel die luftfahrt gehen für die ist
ganz klar sie mussten sich jetzt planen
wir suchen und das ist ein moment wo es
auch in zukunft geht
der sehr frustrierend glaube ich ist das
heißt wächst eine generation nach wo man
früher mal gesagt hätte das ist eine
generation per du also eine verlorene
generation
weil sie quasi aus einem nicht ganz gut
funktionierendes schulsystem in ein
nicht ganz gut funktionieren das
arbeitssysteme übergehen also ich wehre
mich ganz immens gegen den begriff
generation corona oder ähnliches sagen
wir mal negativ behafteten begriffe ich
würde sagen und da bin ich sehr positiv
gestimmt oder ein positiver mensch dass
wir sagen sollten diese generation die
sich jetzt durch wirklich mittlerweile
zwölf monate corona geboxt hat sich
wirklich vieles an eigenen mussten
selbstständigkeit gerade bei den
jüngsten immenses geleistet haben zu
hause
ich würde das eher so sehen dass das
eigentlich ein positiver aspekt ist die
menschen die jetzt eben zu hause waren
wir wir schüler wir sind diejenigen die
tatsächlich echt vieles geleistet haben
und von daher würde ich sagen ich glaube
wir können am ende eigentlich stolz
darauf sein und am ende auch in einem
einigen jahrzehnten sagen können mit
stolz wir waren generation corona und
nicht im negativen sinne
wenn sie berater der bundesregierung
werde oder der ministerpräsidenten was
würden sie ihm raten vor allem mit blick
auf die schülerinnen und schüler jetzt
zu tun
wir brauchen die klaren ansagen die wir
schon immer gefordert haben und vor
allem braucht es auch jetzt gerade im
bezug auf infektionsschutz und et cetera
ganz klare strategien seit wochen hören
wir immer priorität sind die schulen ich
kann das tatsächlich einfach nicht mehr
hören gehören immer wieder wir sind das
wichtigste ist die bildung und und dabei
was das tatsächlich in der praxis
bedeutet das konnte ich bis jetzt nicht
erleben es ist immer noch der frage wie
werden die tests an den schulen
umgesetzt nordrhein westfalen hat
gestern gesagt sie geben jetzt tests an
die schulen da fehlt aber bis heute noch
die ansage wie soll das geschehen wer
beaufsichtigt das wie und von daher
finde ich man sollte er sich einen plan
überlegen und dann reden und nicht reden
und dann eine planung entwickeln
verstehe ich gar nicht gut
nachvollziehen das heißt sie fordern
auch eine klare linie und eine klare
umsetzungen auch einen entspannteren
umgang mit der ganzen situation weil sie
sagen grundsätzlich sind wir positiv
gestimmt mit blick auf die zukunft von
der politik würde ich mir kein
entspannteren umgang wünschen denn ich
habe den eindruck der ist schon zu
entspannt ich würde mir aber natürlich
grundsätzlich in der gesellschaft was
heißt wünschen aber ich glaube dass die
gesellschaft wie das leistet und ich
glaube dass wir
neben all den negativen sachen ich meine
wir sterben jeden tag immer noch ganz
viele menschen
das ist nicht schön zu reden aber ich
glaube dass wir auch mit blick auf deine
zeit nachgeholt niemals uns das positive
wegnehmen lassen dürfen sagt dario
schreiben mit einem impuls von den
schülerinnen und schüler der
bundesschülerkonferenz und aller schulen
in die gesellschaft und in die politik
ich sage danke für dieses gespräch
wünsche ihnen einen guten tag gehen
wünsche ich ihnen auch tschüss danke